My name is Raymond Young. I am the
Division Chief for Psychosomatic
Medicine, or Consultation Liaison
Services, in our Department of Psychiatry
for Emory Healthcare. Psychosomatic
medicine is the interplay between
medicine and psychiatric illness, so it
involves looking at patients who are
medically ill and addressing potentially
their psychiatric needs. What I enjoy
most about it is the teaching, the
education. I like being involved with our
young learners. They offer new
perspectives, allow us to think about our
patients differently. My interest in
behavior goes back to early childhood.
As a young child I was a shy person, so I
wanted to learn why was I shy, so that
was one of the reasons why I got
interested in that. I grew up in the Bay
Area in a city called Hayward, California.
I grew up with a father who's an OB/GYN,
so I grew up being a son of a doctor, and
my mother, she was dealing with a chronic
illness of lupus, and I saw her be very
proactive and managing her own care
while taking care of us. So I grew up in
a household where education was
important. It was already determined that
we were going to college . There wasn't a
question of "After high school what are
you gonna do?" It was like "After college
what are you gonna do?" I went to college
at UC Berkeley. I went to medical school at what
was called the Medical College of Ohio
in Toledo, and I finished my residency at
Rush Presbyterian in Chicago, Illinois.
My wife and I adopted baby boy, his name
is Jacob.
We met at our siblings' wedding, so her
older sister and my younger brother are
married, and so we met at their wedding.
I asked her out and we started dating and
then we got married. I enjoy working with
the geriatric population. One of the
things that Emory does very well is that
we have a day hospitalization program
called "Transitions" which is a five-day-a-week
program that is focused on the
geriatric population who are dealing
with essentially transitions in life --
loss of spouse, loss of independence,
mood disorders, and they engage in groups,
do individual therapy, do medication management.
My legacy? That that's a challenging question.
I'd like to develop
a more proactive approach, where we're
more engaged and actively involved with
the services so that we can see more of
their patients. I think some of the key
to doing that is having more
integrative care.
I think Emory's is in the process of doing
that, and we have a lot of settings that
we're doing that -- that's what the Brain
Health Center is meant to be.
I enjoy seeing my patients. I've been
seeing some of my patients for over ten years,
and it's nice to see them grow and get
better and improve.
And of course there's always
challenges with new patients and trying
to figure out how I can best help them.